I really tell him,
I celebrate that after 20 years in this chamber,
has begun to take an interest in what is happening in Spain.
But if I really wanted to help,
if I really wanted to help,
my recommendation,
Mr. Weber,
is that our country lived before
and do not just repeat
unfounded proclamations
that colleagues in the Spanish Popular Party pass on to them.
Tell me, Mr.
Weber,
do you know
Who are the allies of the Popular Party in Spain?
Do you know what Vox represents and what it thinks?
Do you really know how Vox defines the European Union?
I quote you verbatim,
defines it as 1 Federal mega-state,
similar to the Soviet Union.
Spain,
ladies and gentlemen,
is 1 democracy,
is 1 full democracy.
We are a Europeanist country,
as is its government.
Spain has a robust rule of law,
1 absolutely legitimate and capable government.
And I invite you not to confuse yourself with your opponent.
This mistake
already committed by the European right wing in the past
and Europe paid dearly for it,
nothing more.
And thank you very much,
gentlemen